hello there
back in 2020 when the world went into
lockdown
i decided to try minecraft i'd never
played before and wanted to document a
noobs play through
why because we only get one opportunity
to play a game
for the very first time and as minecraft
is a game which revolves around passing
information from player to player
i thought this would be a good challenge
the rules of the adventure were simple
defeat the enderdragon without any help
from
anyone at all today marks the end of
this series
i did it i beat the enderdragon all
alone and it's been one hell of a
journey
a quick recap of milestones in the first
100 days
i slowly understood farming and by the
end of the episode i ventured into the
nether for the very first time
on the way to 200 days i got to grips
with building
and i learned to enchant and i got so
lost in the nether
i had to start in a brand new area on
day 200
i saw a new enemy and that's where we'll
pick up the story
[Music]
i quickly got to work in my new home and
protected the portal from invaders
after clearing the area i saw a village
close by and by the end of day two
i'd made a shopping mall i took all the
villagers and gave them professions
and put them all in one place safely
locked away like a prison
over the first week here i power leveled
these guys to see what they would sell
me
and it's cool stuff like swords that set
enemies ablaze
and enchantment books which make me take
less damage from fire
this was the one aspect of minecraft i
never really wanted to bother with
but i'm so glad i did day three arrived
and i went straight back into the nether
to
find that flaming enemy you'll find i
give everything my own names in this
series as i simply can't go online to
check
just in case they're spoilers so unless
it kills me it gets a new name
just like derek or the pig dudes or the
rack hives
or the slender endermen whilst in the
nether i found these guys the black
skeletons
i cheated the system and wrecked them
all collecting four blaze rods in the
process
i had no idea why i needed them back
then but this
was a big moment on day four the
marauders approached and i decided to
challenge myself
could i start a raid and keep all my
villagers alive
it wasn't going to be easy i had tried
this twice before and failed both times
but now i felt strong enough to protect
and attack
everything was going to plan i was
collecting banners like they were going
out of fashion
and then i remembered the real problem
here these things these brahma balls
i hatched a plan to take them out and
over the next three days
i survived the raid afterwards i checked
on the family and everyone made it
through
this was great only a few stragglers to
take care of
and then i was killed by a vex
a damn vex i don't know what a vex is
the following day the plan was to find
my way back home to the hobbit house
but i wanted to stack up on those blaze
rods i wasn't sure how easy it would be
to find another one of those spawners
i got over 30 in the end after saying
goodbye to the villagers
and stocking up on supplies and mending
my weapons and armor
i walked home through the nether day
nine brought me to a pig castle
i was surprised attacked constantly and
barely survived
this place was full of items i'd never
heard of but now i have
golden carrots and a music disc why
i don't know but this is cool over three
days i followed the path back home
and finally i got there i had to fight
my way through so many of these pig
dudes but i'm back
it felt great to celebrate i went on top
of hot watch and randomly started
throwing things like
chickens and flame rods as you do but
then this randomness
led to something fantastic i
accidentally used an ender pearl
and discovered teleportation 211 days
i've been here
and i'm still finding things that are
blowing my mind before i accidentally
commit sudoku
i set my spawn point here i don't want
to take that three-day journey ever
again
day 212 there was no rest for the wicked
i ran out of bread and needed more food
to the farm i go and yes i went to visit
my animals too
another rack hive attacked reminding me
i really need to sleep one of these days
day 213 i woke up with a great deal to
do
i made a room let's call this a museum
the plan is to make
everything i've never made before and
plonk it in this room
until it has a use now i'm back home
resources are plentiful
and throughout my trips to the nether i
have so many things i don't know what to
do with
like ancient debris and i even have a
totem of undying
that sounds important i thought by
making everything in the recipe book i'd
have a better chance of finding the
enderdragon before day 300.
the next day i got totally sidetracked
and made an ender dude
out of the excess wool i've had i'm
trying my best to keep building so i
keep improving i ran out of wall the
same day this will be finished
one day okay day 15. yes i know it would
be better with obsidian
but that takes so long to mine i'm
sticking with wool
just before day broke the following
morning the ender dude was complete
but he had brown eyes because i don't
have any purple wool yet
and i haven't decided what he should be
holding yet i need to get back to the
job at hand
building everything that's possible so
please ignore all the sheep all over the
world right now
we've got better things to do day 217 i
made tnt
and attempted to blow up the mountain to
the right of my house
it was great fun through the night i
crafted other items like this brewing
stand
which again i'm clueless about looks
like i need potions and not bread
now day 218 this was the greatest day
looking back at my time in the game
i concentrated my efforts on crafting
things that included fire like those
rods i picked up in the nether
and eventually created an eye of the
ender
i really thought this was going to be
some sort of superpower teleporter
so i threw it i was completely wrong
it sort of hovers there and i think it
wants me to follow it
without delay i tossed another into the
air and the adventure began
it was slow progress it really was and
then suddenly
the bloody thing broke into pieces these
shenanigans
are already over i now knew what i
needed to do craft as many eye vendors
as i could
and follow them to a secret location
just like frodo and sam
i grabbed my wares and set off on an
adventure the mission to find the secret
location was long
i ran for miles desperately hoping each
eye wouldn't shatter
i swam across rivers up waterfalls i
fought enemies i ran day
and night never stopping which led me to
this forest
on day 20. i'll cut this down i
continued to throw the eyes in the air
but i completely lost them
turns out the eye wanted me to go
underground we're going down
so i made a shovel and started digging
for what i thought
was going to be treasure an achievement
hit and i'd made it to an underground
facility
the corridors were winding it was almost
a maze
jail cells scattered throughout and so
many dead ends it took over a day to
explore
but then i found it this thing a ring of
eyeballs
but alas some were missing luckily i had
quite a few ender eyes
which i then put in and of course i
needed more to claim this underworld
treasure
which meant i needed to go back home and
restock
i brought with me enough mats to build
an ender portal i figured out that
distances in the nether are shorter than
in this top side of the world
so i try to get home this way oh and by
the way i attempted to build a lot of
the ring style tower here in this new
location to help me find it easier
but it doesn't look very good at all i
wanted to remove all the stone from the
underground facility
and put it here and like usual my habit
of not finishing things i start
continues i'll come back to it you have
my word
day 23 i made the portal and went back
home
okay i went the wrong direction first
but eventually i got home
and on that day i started to fight any
enderman
who wanted a piece of this i needed
their pearls
day 25 and 26 were a restock few days
back on the farm which means more
mundane tasks
and at this point in the series i've
completely stopped showing you when i'm
strip mining every night or two i come
back down here and smash walls until i
find diamonds
but i needed much more this time so i
went down for 40 minutes and came back
with 22 diamonds
not too shabby at all plot twist whilst
down in the mine i realized i'd never
figured out what redstone dust
actually does i put that right on day 27
my first experience was a failure i
tried to use it like it was a bomb fuse
but eventually i had an epiphany and
thanks to my track experiments from the
very first episode
i used the lever and sure enough i
started to understand redstone dust
it's like circuitry let the experiment
continue
on day 28 i made everything with the
word redstone in it
it meant more trips to the nether but
all the time i'm fighting endermen
to get more of those pearls and yeah
look i made a light switch
the next day i made a dispenser i tried
to make an automatic bow
it's awesome but i can't make it shoot
repeatedly
but i'm definitely learning day 30 i
moved on to pistons
pushy little blocks of awesomeness i was
immediately addicted to the
possibilities of redstone and i also
began to understand power sources
and the weakening signal that continues
and redstone torch oh this is so much
i'll just shut up it was getting sciency
but another piston caught my eye the
sticky piston
ever since i bought the big green jelly
i've always wanted to know the purpose
of that slime
and now i have the chance i slept to
prepare myself for a day of science
the next morning i learned how to move
blocks with sticky pistons
my plan was to create a redstone door
which automatically opened using
pressure plates it took three days it
took so long
but look a golden door it's far better
than i imagined
but now i have random redstone dust
unhidden here which is a bit of an
eyesore
but in terms of functionality i made a
door
like a real man i hope my dad is proud
of me
when day 33 arrived i celebrated my
achievements and made fireworks
they look nice and all but i feel this
is a complete waste of gunpowder
also i fought more into dudes i'm always
scrapping with these guys now
the next day i stacked all my pearls
together and used my final stashes of
blaze powder to make the last eye
avengers i will ever need
it's time to go back to that castle
ruins the journey is now microscopic
thanks to the nether
i arrived almost immediately and
inserted the eyes
and of course i'm missing one so back to
fighting ender dude some more
frustratingly non dropped all day and
then xander told me to try at nighttime
check it at night check it at night okay
let's see if he's right damn it he's
right don't tell him stupid
five-year-old anyway we have the final
piece of the puzzle
and now it's time to open the mega
portal
i was shook off by the animation and
also a little scared
so like most scientists before me i
threw a carrot in there to check
how it works and yep it's certainly a
portal
so i'm not sure if i can get back so
this got me really worried
i guess this is where we fight the ender
dragon only one way to find out
is this the end of the story all those
months ago a noob
tried to find the end dragon without any
help is this really it
i arrived everything clicked into place
the end is here i can see
the ender dragon's health and of course
i didn't know how to get out and went
the wrong way but eventually
i came face to face with the ender
dragon
immediately he spat a plume of toxic
purple vomit at me
i was trapped so this was my chance to
see how long the purple puke stuck
around for
it's 36 seconds if you're interested
during this time i heard the endermen
and made a choice to build a house for
protection i needed somewhere safe
should i ever look an enderman in the
eyes good thing i did because eight
attacked me the moment i looked around
using my mini home i could wipe them out
without risking any
injury i took my opportunity to venture
forwards towards the dragon
i hit him with a crossbow shot but his
health didn't take a hit at all
looking around i saw these pillars which
looked to be protecting him
so i took a cheeky shot at one and
yeah now we've got a plan take down all
the pillars i made a second home in the
center of the island
but this was my undoing i didn't think
fast enough and died
to the puke poisoning this was going to
be a tough run
back in the overworld i ran straight
back in to get my items
and finished off the second shack taking
more shots to break the curse on the
pillars
but a new issue faced me some of the
pillars were protected
and my crossbow was useless a new plan
was needed
and thanks to the endermen i knew what i
needed to do use those pearls to
teleport up high
it worked but due to my previous death i
didn't know where my pickaxe was
and yeah i died again two nil two nail
ender dragon okay two nil
day 37 arrived and i needed to think
this through
i'm okay with my stretch there i don't
think there was anything i could really
change
but my ability to take damage was
definitely a problem
i kept in mind i still had 60 days to
get that fight won
so i put on my last suit of armor back
home i checked my furnaces
i made netherite scrap from ancient
debris and according to the recipe book
i needed one more piece of gold to craft
it
so i stole it and made my first ever
netherright ingot
look at all the things i can make in the
top corner but nothing was actually in
the recipe book so
once again i had no idea how to make
near the right weapons and armor
and i feel they would be useful about
now on day 238 i decided the giant
enderman outside
needed to have something to hold so i
grabbed a marauder banner
and i remade it i find these kinds of
things really tranquil
especially when the sun rose i think my
favorite thing in minecraft is
collecting marauder banners
by the way you've seen how i get down
from the enderman but did you know how i
get up
he has a ladder straight up to his
butthole
i always want to know day 239 i decided
to go back to the tower i started
building at the end portal
i gave myself a week of time in game to
finish this
let's do this hit the montage music
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
uh just in case you're thinking i have
some sort of survival skill please note
i died four times making this build each
time i regathered my things and mined
more stone
and continued the build by the way day
43 is super boring i needed around
200 obsidian blocks that was so painful
but hopefully worth it because on day 47
i finished it my first mega build big
benny the minecraft clock
hang on i can improve this that's better
i left the game running to capture a
cool time lapse of the day night cycle
but when i returned
i was dead that was fun i'm happy with
the final build
it's nothing fancy but shows a
progression in skill i hope i think i
prefer the building side of minecraft
compared to the survival elements
sometimes
but gathering mats is so painstaking but
when it comes together
and you build something you're proud of
it's totally worth it let me just go
back a couple of days this is what i
figured out on day 46
i can use water to get up and down
safely
i feel so dumb for not figuring this out
200 days earlier
this would have negated so many of my
deaths but i'm glad i know this now
because every day is a school day day 50
i spent a few days in the mines to get
my xp level high enough to enchant my
gear to a high standard
and now mark this day in your calendar
day 252
the day i beat the ender dragon at the
moment
i've died twice but i will have the
final say in this war
this time i brought water to safely
climb down the pillars with the iron
covers
this method was simple end a pearl to
teleport break the covering
use a bucket to escape hit the new
opening with a crossbow bolt
i knew not to stand too close i'm
guessing we explode if we may lay these
the water became a pivotal way to take
out the other pillar crystals too
this was going completely to plan
and now the ender dragon had nowhere to
hide it was time to end this
which took a very very long time
[Music]
2 000 years later in the last moment the
ender dragon was on the smallest amount
of health possible i needed to end this
in the most epic of ways i waited for
the beast to land
and then i clocked him upside the head
to mark the end
of this noob quest
[Music]
the credits began to roll the minecraft
noob had done it
i found and defeated the ender dragon
without any help from anyone
or anything i really felt like i
accomplished something today
i immediately then went on to twitter
and youtube and unblocked the word
minecraft
i'm now allowing myself to look at
guides and tips and see how other people
make content around this game
i kept going until day 300 but i feel
that this is a really good end point
because everything i make after this
point
is not personal anymore it's due to a
guide and i'm really thankful for those
for example a chat called mumbo jumbo
taught me redstone stairs which i made
on day63
all thanks to tutorials and once i was
told how to get netherite armor
i had a full set by day 90. i suddenly
could do
anything because all the information was
there at a button click
i found the lytra wings these things
changed everything about how i got
around
but looking back i'm happy i played the
first part of this without any help at
all
the memories i've made will make
minecraft memorable forever
and now i've got to a point where i'm
not sure what to do next maybe try
hardcore
and see if i'm up to the challenge or
maybe get my son xander involved
and play my first game of duo minecraft
i'll let you decide what we do next and
if you'd like any more minecraft content
from
me but now on day 300 i wanted to thank
you for putting up with my nonsense
noob life is tough but we did this i'm
adam from playstation grenade it's been
a pleasure
i'll see you next time
you